here is an example of a problem related
to the Bernoulli process which can be
tricky but is actually easy to answer if
one makes good use of the fresh start
property here is the setting time is
discrete divided into slots we have a
server that receives tasks to process
tasks received get processed in the same
time slot so slots are divided into busy
ones those are the slots during which a
task gets processed and idle slots these
are the slots during which there is no
task to be processed we assume that the
process of job arrivals is described by
a Bernoulli process with some known
parameter P so during each slot there is
probability P that the job is present
and different slots are independent of
each other we're interested in the first
busy period of the server the first busy
period starts at the first slot during
which there is a job present and the
busy period extends until just before
the next idle slot for an example it
could be the case that the first slot is
busy in which case the busy period
starts right here and the busy period in
this example extends for three time
units it ends just before the next idle
slot it could also be the case that the
first slot is idle in that case the busy
period starts with the first busy slot
that shows up it's this slot in this
example and extends until just before
the first idle slot that we observe so
in this example the busy period extends
for four time steps what is the length
of the first busy period well the length
of the first busy period is a random
variable so what we mean by this
question is what is the distribution of
this random variable
here's how we go about it the process
starts we wait until a first busy slot
appears this is a random time which is
actually the first arrival time and at
that time by our earlier discussion the
process will start fresh starting from
this next slot here and going on forward
what we have is a Bernoulli process and
at each slot there's probability P that
it is busy and probability 1 minus P
that it is idle now what is this slot
here this is the first idle slot in this
Bernoulli process that starts fresh at
this particular time at each time step
there is probability 1 minus P that the
slot is idle think now of idle slots as
successes
how long does it take until the first
success we know that this is a geometric
random variable with parameter with
parameter equal to the probability of
success since we are thinking of the
idle slot as being a success the
parameter in this case is going to be 1
minus P so the length of this blue
interval that starts at this slot and
extends until the first idle slot has a
geometric distribution with parameter 1
minus P but now notice that the length
of this blue interval is exactly the
same as the length of this red interval
the red interval is just the same as the
blue interval but shifted by one but
their lengths are the same and the
length of the red interval is the length
of the first busy period so we conclude
that the first busy period is also a
geometric random variable with parameter
1 - P